welcome to this video playing
international master town tavern from
the UK check the Scandinavian with
Knight f6 this is a very yeah very
uncommon line nowadays it's not done
it's not particularly bad it's just not
very very popular so quite often leading
to positions where white is a bit more
comfortable without any anything special
going on it's a bit strange what what
he's doing here but probably not
seriously bad you should be for us a bit
strange I was intending to to fianchetto
anyway now
okay so I thought Bishop Bishop to age
six or something otherwise I don't
really see the point of Bishop f4
ok so just fianchetto the the bishop
yeah this is a somewhat wacky p set up
bishop on h6 here looks like someone
accidentally dropped it down mmm yeah i
really don't i really don't want to an
hour of the sex change I mean move this
night and allow them to exchange on c1
so it's probably not bad but doesn't
feel like the most ambitious way to play
and five is a move that I wonder about
hmm yeah this is some interesting move
I'm wondering uh no f-4s completely
idiotic you can just take it because of
the age 49 hanging
hmm interesting
complicated position the idea is to
control each five so that you cannot
play you five and maybe I'm able to play
something like 94 takes Bishop h6
something like that d damaging the pawn
structure may be also a form f4 is also
interesting idea just blocking all this
and then play Knight f3 35 maybe g4g
five even this is based on the fact that
he doesn't really have porn breaks in
the center the knight on c6 is blocking
the sea porn and it's not so clear what
what you should do now he doesn't want
to take on the tool this would be a big
concession maybe
maybe he can play 97 or something like
that
they spending spending too much time
here I mean I I'm very slow and tend to
think far too long but this seems like
you're much too long a thing okay so
trying to play against this this bishop
okay drop back
and getting getting g45 that's an
additional idea
he's not retreating
ok G form
you can maybe reply g5 as weird as it
looks I know the nav man night f5 is not
really on maybe this 193 or just or
regrouping there it's not too bad and I
could have played g6 and now i can play
g4 no doubt about that g4s strong now
threatening g5 this was some a big
threat and with Queen going away from b7
this is no working night everyone also
protected the g5 square yeah I can just
grab only for now right
okay so g5 yep keeping keeping it closed
okay let's no let's oops Vic let's get
the night back into play it's a it's
better to put postage here to 21 to
cover the center
yeah the only has this one good piece
but it's a good piece no no don't maybe
get night f7 into the mix isn't this
winning night of seven yeah come on this
is this is really looking Jack super
dangerous Oh create a go 25 just what
all this now this is good enough so what
now 25 Bishop h3 shining like that maybe
not the most precious but it looks like
check the quiet quite secure one black
for effects aren't I should be five and
if he takes the screen f6 or 25 and yeah
Queen f6 or 25 I could have played 25
immediately it was a bit bit simpler and
this was very interesting very
interesting I'm strategical battle here
he spent so much time though this is
what's getting getting a bit bit too
tricky yeah I don't think that black
isn't in bad shape p.m. actually it
looks a bit artificial but it shouldn't
be shouldn't be bad and here now here
it's interesting starting here I didn't
want to move the night because this
would help him to solve his issue with
this this
rh6 might in fact here night be three as
a good news must take take attacking at
the bishop and then this one yeah this
is an eye this is a bit too deep at
least for me in a blitz game this leads
to a good position for white yeah I mean
to see that this is a good position it's
not difficult but you see that
beforehand I just have the very strong
bishop and this is just weak I mean the
light squares are basically week okay
this was also interesting but far less
convincing you know f4 try to prevent
all the breaks night c4 was interesting
now I played this one attending g4 and
here I ran right into that and now g4 is
just just not defensible anymore g5 it
just winds a piece those pieces are so
badly placed that he cannot prevent that
he went went from this and this is just
just a direct loss material I the two
pieces for the rook and I've got an
overwhelming space advantage interesting
so what should he have done probably
probably here do some simplifying like
this song I mean yeah it is a bit of a
liability this this will set up maybe
here maybe here's something like that
exchanging stuff there's also queen bee
three
this position looks some surprisingly
tricky for black it's not a very natural
setup or this I mean not not be six I
mean the kind of those pieces are all in
front of pawns this is what I'm talking
about and very often those pieces are
vulnerable look at my pieces they're
basically all coordinated with the with
the pawns behind them and working
together and blacks pieces are always a
bit liable a bit bit unstable here
interesting thanks for watching